[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today is something a little different
those who know me understand that I have
this innate need to collect video game
related items I mean look at my office
wall I can't help myself
even my coasters are video game related
well to my surprise when I returned home
today this beast was sitting on my desk
this must be the biggest collector's
edition in gaming history and to those
that don't know already this is the
Darksiders 3 apocalypse edition which
retails here in the UK for 400 pounds oh
well I thought we should open it
together and I'll tell you a little bit
about the game in the process you ready
let's do this
inside this hulking great box there a
host of items but it's all about these 4
figurines from Darksiders history I
presume they would be the Four Horsemen
of the Apocalypse in Darksiders they are
fury war death and strife this lady here
is fury
and is whom we play as in docksiders 3
the chart council have tasked her with
hunting down and destroying the seven
deadly sins she's got the tools for the
job just look at that impressive whip
although previous Darksiders games were
all about hack and slash plain like the
old god of war titles darkside 2 3 is
actually a bit more Souls like so it
could be a really good starting point
for new players to the series and
there's also other reasons where you can
start with any of the games I'll get to
that in a moment but anyway the second
character here is war and he was the
protagonist in the very first darkside
it's game that game set up all the
conflicts of the world with Heaven and
Hell fighting over the power of creation
the Four Horsemen were created to keep
these two in balance but of course it
didn't go to plan and all hell breaks
loose and heaven too for that matter
what a signature weapon was a two-handed
sword named chaos eater I wanted to call
my newborn son chaos eater them milady
disagreed typical war is imprisoned for
starting the apocalypse earlier than
prophesized which brings us to the next
character this guy is death and you've
guessed it he was the main character in
Darksiders - death is so sure of his
brothers innocence that he sets out to
save humanity who so happened to be
annihilated when the apocalypse began
check out
damn sides the detail on these figures
is insane before I get too sidetracked
the great thing about the dark side is
games is that each of the games happens
parallel to the others well technically
Darksiders one happens first but that
does involve a little bit of time
trouble anyway let's open the next
figure number four so I was expecting
the fourth horseman strike but nope
this is vulgrim the merchant in the dark
side a series strife will have to wait
until he gets his own game before we get
10 inches of him that was the very weird
thing to say Adam moving on so vulgrim
he's a demon who accepts different types
of currency for the items he sells and
buy currency and means souls he also
accepts coins and bahtman tokens and
Walmart vouchers
maybe not the latter one so those were
the statues that THQ Nordik kindly sent
to me alongside a few other goodies in
the apocalypse Edition including a
fabric poster of Fury looking lovely a
pendant of the Darksiders logo and a
steelbook version of the game there's
even a soundtrack here and the greatest
thing of all a Darksiders 3 art book
it's a bit spoilery so i'll not show too
much but i absolutely adore these things
so what do you think do you think all
this is worth 400 pounds I'm sure if
you're a collector like me you do think
so anyway this has been an absolute
pleasure what do you think - darkside is
3 I attempted to try it because I'm
tempted to go back and play them all
back to back to back it's because of the
lore about the apocalypse not enough
games cover that subject matter anyway
I'll go back to standard content
tomorrow but if you did enjoy this
please let me know and I'll add
unboxings to the schedule and if you
don't like it just tell me why just so I
learn from this experience
anyway I'm Adeline from PlayStation
granade it's been a bloody pleasure I'll
see you next time
[Music]